[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello
and welcome to nasa's jet propulsion
laboratory in southern california
where we have just landed the most
sophisticated and most capable rover yet
on the surface of mars the perseverance
are over
i'm jari cook of jpl's digital news and
media office and i'll be your host today
as we gather reactions from our key
players from the landing and also give a
glimpse of what's to come
so because of the coronavirus pandemic
everything's going to look a little
different today we have our masks on and
the layout is a little different
but i want to introduce our speakers to
you so standing on the floor of von
karman auditorium
we have steve jurissic nasa's acting
administrator
we also have mike watkins the director
of jpl
and then we also have john mcnamee
perseverance's project manager
up on the stage we have thomas zerbukin
nasa's associate administrator for the
science mission directorate
we have lori glaze nasa's planetary
science director
we have matt wallace the perseverance
deputy project manager
and al chen entry descent and landing
lead
ken farley the perseverance project
scientist
and then coming from our surface
operations area we have jennifer trosper
deputy project manager and over here we
have a special group on our video
conference we have a group of the
perseverance team members
um all right so we are going to be
taking questions during this briefing so
if you're a member of the media and
you're on our phone lines press star one
and you'll be put into the queue and if
you're on social media
use the hashtag countdown to mars but
before i turn it over turn over the
podium i just wanted to take one minute
to recognize what a thrilling day today
has been
we now have the most ambitious rover yet
on the surface of mars congratulations
all right i'm gonna turn the podium over
to steve jurissic
wow i mean just just an amazing
incredible day um i could not be
uh more proud of the team and what
they've
done what they've accomplished under uh
under challenging circumstances
i also have to tell you that about an
hour after landing i got a phone call
from the president of the united states
and uh and he's his first words were
congratulations man
and i knew it was him i wasn't getting
punked i didn't only
only president said congratulations man
he um
he he talked about um how
proud he was of what we accomplished um
and he wanted me to i wanted me to send
my his regards to percy
and he wanted to congratulate the team
he wanted me to congratulate team for
him
he does want to congratulate the team
personally and i told him we will make
that happen
and so i'm looking forward to having the
president united states congratulate the
team this week um
you know nine successful landings on
mars
um the only nation that's been able to
do that just just
incredible um thousands of people
working on this to make this happen
at the jet propulsion lab at nasa
centers
with our industry partners and our
international partners
i want to call out one of our other
government agency partners the
department of energy
develops the radio isotopic thermal
generators first the rtds
that power curiosity and our powering uh
perseverance
and it's a great partnership so thank
you to our doe colleagues
um you know this this this mission
is amazing on its own science technology
and caching samples bring back to earth
but it's also part of our bigger
exploration plans
right which involve really understanding
mars
and the evolution of mars and whether
there was life ancient life
but also preparing for eventual human
missions to mars
and so this is one step along the way
of our journey to accomplish that goal
and it's a
major step and we've embarked on that
we've taken the first
steps and embarking on that journey um
you know again i just i just haven't i'm
amazed
that um that uh
that everything went up you know pretty
much according to plan
and um when i heard the touchdown signal
come back
and saw the first image i cannot tell
you how
overcome with emotion i was and happy i
was i didn't get a lot of sleep last
night
i think i'm going to get sleep really
well tonight so
again just it's an amazing day um with
that i would like to turn it over to my
colleague and friend dr zabookin
well thanks so much steve and uh i want
to
share an an event with you with you that
usually happens when i'm by myself
and what you should know is that every
time we do a launch or we do a landing
we get two plans one plan is the one we
want to do
and then there's that second plan which
is right here that's the contingency
plan
here's for the contingency plan all
right
[Applause]
just about one and a half hours a little
bit more
history happened right here and uh
i want to play a video that the team put
together before i do so
i want to just warn you you may or may
not
in the last row see some um
bent coed protocols uh you should just
know
that all of us who are involved back
there were doubly masked and
normally had all the distance in the
world but
but uh you know i will tell you later
about my emotions there but i
i had to hug some people uh sorry for
that uh steve and
and everybody but uh roll the video
please let's lift back
that moment we had go ahead we are
starting to straighten up and fly right
maneuver
in preparation for parachute deploy
the navigation has confirmed that the
parachute has deployed and we are seeing
significant deceleration
skytrain maneuver has started about 20
meters off the surface
we're getting signals from mro
touchdown confirmed
on the surface
looks like we're getting the first image
uh what an amazing moment i have to tell
you
after i was kind of reacting the first
five seconds or so
i was overcome with emotions frankly in
the back there
and i was tearing up and then frankly
what i thought about
is a statement that was made 20 minutes
or so before the moments you just saw
when one of the leaders said this is the
first time for months that we're all in
the same room
and i want to thank you for being here
and being part of the team of course
many individuals on the monitor here and
otherwise
we're not in that room and i just wanted
to tell you how proud
and so moved i was by that team
achieving that amazing success i was
reminded
of uh a statement of a famous coach
who once was asked what are the three
most important things
that create success in the game and it
turns out the same is true for nasa
and here are the following three in the
order of priority
the team the team and the team
and i just really want to thank the team
for that thanks so much
of course for me this is not an end but
a beginning
now the amazing science starts you know
and i just i'm so looking forward
to the signs that's coming come there
every yard
on the surface of mars
is a yard of mars sample return to go
collect these precious samples
and bring them back to earth and of
course you should
know that one of the first texts i got
from the international community was
from my friend
david parker my colleague over in isa
who
sent his congratulations i just want to
tell him back how we're excited we are
to continue to work with them on this
amazing joint mission this international
history-making mission that we're now
enduring of course
with perseverance right there but as
we're already starting to develop
some of the team members moving over
towards
mars sample return and many concrete
steps
are also happening of course towards
another horizon goal which is
human exploration of mars as well you
know i always think of it as like
there's a whole bucket of miracles you
need to achieve
to do that and we're taking some
miracles off the table
both today but also as we go forward
with uh mars
sample return so the future of mars
exploration is just so
broad and exciting and involves many
other nations as well
and uh leaders many of them are still in
school
or even in kindergarten or or or younger
and those leaders we're going to need as
we do this
amazing achieve those amazing goals
i wanna think of the international
partners of uh
mars 2020 perseverance and we had
something like 35
vendors from 11 nations that of course
added up to the nearly thousand within
the united states
eleven nations that included a lot of
them and i've been in some of these
nations and i know
where these pieces are coming from and
how proud those nations are of course
over and above that we have three
partners that have contributed
instruments france
spain and norway and i had texts from
our french colleagues for example
where the prime minister was right there
with the team and celebrating with them
i'm just so glad for the support in each
one of those countries they're receiving
from their governments
and we look forward but each of our
contributions the contributions
internationally and the ones
by the team here will provide
information and then tell us about mars
and also the future collaboration that
will be enabled
by the amazing historic feed today mars
is always hard we don't take
this for granted landing on mars it's
one of the toughest things even though
the team
you know is making it look easy i have
to tell you i mean i it's just
incredible to me i've baffled you know
what i told steve
this morning you know i had to get up in
the night twice to
replace a sweated through wet t-shirt
with a new one
i was telling myself i'm pretty calm
apparently my body did not say so
but uh this next night i'm sure i only
need one of them
as we go forward and that's in no small
way because of my next friend i'm going
to introduce you to you which is of
course
mike watkins who's the jpl director take
it away mike
thank you thomas um i'd like to welcome
everyone virtually to
the jet propulsion laboratory here uh
this room
uh many of our journalist colleagues
have been in this room for a landing day
where we've actually celebrated all of
the mars landings
uh ever accomplished by humankind uh
here in this room and i miss the fact
that uh you're not all here uh with us
today we usually have the lab buzzing
with
thousands of folks and uh because of
covid we're doing this remotely
uh but i hope you still feel a part of
this and uh and certainly feel free to
engage us uh you know with questions and
follow-up
uh on behalf of jpl i have to say we
have a fantastic
project team no question about it and
john mcnamee and matt wallace will talk
a lot more
about that team but i want to also
notice the
rest of jpl it really took a lot of
folks
working together to make this mission
successful and of course we're working
on missions other
than mars perseverance as well and we
had to keep
those missions going we had to keep mars
2020 going uh
we had to use our cio office to make
sure we could all work
uh in a virtual sense work remotely and
of course folks keeping
everyone safe on the lab in terms of ppe
and facility
changes and you know we sort of had to
change the tires while we're going down
the highway
uh starting last year and uh you know we
are very proud of of having um
been able to uh to make 2020 a success
and now that perseverance uh is on the
surface
uh i hope you are sharing the magic
uh that i do personally uh these first
few days on mars
i always think in some sense are the
most magical uh
all of the great panoramas and the color
photos and great science and our sample
acquisition and the helicopter flight
uh you will follow along with those uh
and see them uh in the coming months
uh but there is something special about
the first few days
because we have just landed a
representative of the planet earth uh
on a place on mars that no one has ever
been to
no one has ever seen it except from
orbital imagery from a few hundred miles
up
uh above mars and uh i believe that that
magical sense that we bring is a lot of
the reason that jpl exists and that
exists
and i and everyone at the lab
is very proud to be to be part of that
and now to talk more about what we
expect to do with this mission on the
surface
now that we are safely down i'd like to
turn it over to my colleague dr lori
glaze
the head of the planetary science
division at nasa headquarters
thank you thanks so much mike really
appreciate it yeah i mean i
just wow right i there's just so much uh
excitement and and emotion here today
and and i
of course have to um extend my thanks as
well
um to the entire team who really had to
work under
adverse conditions over the last year
but have worked hard
for the six years prior to that as well
um and and probably even before that
leading up to to the beginning of the
when the project got kicked off
um i'd also like to to make sure i give
a little shout out and some thanks to to
my headquarters staff that support this
as well
um you know we we all work together it's
all one one big team and i i wanted to
tell the folks
here the the march 2020 team uh that it
was just such an honor to
to be here and be allowed to sit in the
control room with you guys y'all are
incredible you're amazing um and i know
it wasn't even the full team there and
the full breadth of that team
uh the capabilities are are just
astounding and and so i'm just so proud
of everything you've accomplished and
and you know thank you for letting me be
a part of it here today
um it is really truly exciting you know
the
now that we're on the ground um now the
fun really starts and i loved uh you
know you're going to hear
hear from ken in a little bit um we're
talking to him right after landing and
then you know
the science team's already getting
started they're already working you know
ken's in there looking at the pictures
uh the first two that we got down and
he's already uh
you know looking at him and trying to
figure out you know what we're going to
do and where we are
so fantastic i can't wait to get all the
instruments turned on over the next
uh several days and weeks and start
collecting data
um and in particular over the you know
the next few days as we're
we're getting down all of the the
imaging and the microphone data that
we're taking during the descent
uh you know i think it's going to take
us all along on that descent we're all
going to get to experience just exactly
what that was like this will be the
first time we've ever had that
opportunity
to not just look at the the data that
came back and said yes the parachute
deployed and
yes you know the the sky crane operated
correctly we're going to get to see it
and live it
and participate every one of us on that
way down it's going to be amazing so
really really looking forward to that
um i'd also like to uh in my time here
give a shout out to the more than 1
million students that joined in
for the mars student challenge and i
want to i want to thank you all
for can we all thank the students that
participated
fantastic we're just so excited that uh
so many
young people around the country and
around the world have have gotten
engaged with this mission uh it's
incredibly inspiring
and as thomas said it's it's your
generation that's going to take us
forward it's your generation that's
going to be
uh analyzing these samples when they
come back to earth
and we're just uh so happy to have uh so
much
of uh so much interaction with with the
students and
and the uh the mars challenge the
student challenge is still up there and
folks can still
sign up and still participate um in that
activity so
just continue to to participate so with
that
um i am going to pass things over
uh to john um thank you so much john
mcnamee who is our project manager
and congratulations john thank you so
much thank you lori
um so i woke up this morning um unlike
thomas and steve i slept like a baby and
i'll tell you why in a minute
um got a little exercise i had a little
breakfast
landed on mars so all in all pretty good
day so far
and the reason i slept so well is i
probably closer knowledge than uh thomas
uh island and steve and lori
of the quality of the team that was
brought to bear on this
very very difficult endeavor and i'm
talking about the
very much extended uh team uh that
doesn't
just include jpl we got tremendous
support from
nasa headquarters from jpl management
the technical establishment that exists
here
at jpl in the technical divisions but
also
in industry at the other nasa centers
that
were brought to bear on this project our
international partners
and uh a you know a wealth of
contractors uh that contributed
uh greatly to the the success of this
mission
uh so we all celebrate it uh together
together
for sure um it was a very difficult task
uh that we asked people to do uh they
delivered
uh they tested uh and we landed and now
we've turned it over to the operations
team you'll hear from jennifer trosper
here in a minute
and the science team you'll hear from
ken farley in a minute
um and they have uh now they have a job
to do
i mean a real job to do now that we put
this down on on
the surface um i know that the
surface team and the science team
were anxious for us to get there and
then as we started to get there they go
oh my god they're actually going to get
there
if we need to finish doing what we need
to do to operate this rover
well they did that and they'll start
doing in fact they're doing it as we
speak right now
so anyway thanks to all who contributed
i would argue that if you looked up
perseverance uh
in the dictionary you should see the
faces of all of these people
that are on the screen here and all the
people on this
panel so thank you very much i'm gonna
turn it over
to my partner in crime
and the person i called the conscience
of the project
essentially from the get-go matt wallace
thank you very much john and and thank
you for your your leadership
it's been a pleasure working with you
the last uh eight years i have to say
um you know you just got a chance to
watch
this team do one of the hardest things
we do in our business which is to land a
spacecraft
on the planet mars you know we arrived
at mars
moving at about 12 000 miles an hour
roughly
and just seven short minutes we had to
slow down
and and gently put perseverance down in
jezreel crater
and uh and the the system just performed
uh
flawlessly you know uh get through
10 or 12 g's of deceleration a
supersonic parachute deployment
uh you know eight big main engines had
to fire
our terrain relative navigation hazard
avoidance system had to perform the way
it was designed
and uh you know it's just a it's
never easy uh these things are so
complicated uh we were running
a couple million lines of flight
software code i think we had something
on the order of 30 000 parameters to set
and get them all right uh you know just
a it's just a
difficult thing to do and uh it's it's a
real
um very gratifying and quite a relief
to be through it i have to say uh
and the good news is i think the
spacecraft is in in great shape
um we got through edl very well
al chan will give you a little more
information about that
we did transition into our surface mode
as we expected to
and and so we're doing well we do have a
couple images i'm going to pop these up
i think on the screen if you can bring
up our has cam
imagery these are engineering camera
uh images that are taken out the front
of the vehicle
and the rear of the vehicle when we land
and that's jezreel crater right there
and you could see the shadow of the
vehicle
uh and you can look out into the horizon
and uh that is uh that is just uh a
great thing to see
for the team so um
so the next thing we're going to do here
is something we've never tried before
uh in addition to landing at jezreel
crater
um we have never tried to bring the team
into
uh our press conference here and we want
to try to do that
so are you guys ready out there comms
team ready you guys ready to try this
okay i think i'm getting some nods up
and down all right
here we go we're going to try to switch
over
and introduce you to the mars 2020
perseverance team here you go
congratulations team
yeah okay
this is the team that built the
computers they built the structures they
built the radars
they integrated the prop tanks and the
thrusters and all the engines
you know they built actuators and robot
arms and sampling systems
these guys just just never never rested
all of our terrific ins science
instruments our
our technology payloads uh really
a remarkable team uh and they did it
they did it you know days they did it
nights they did it weekends they work
through holidays
they work first shift second shift third
shift
uh just a remarkable um you know a
remarkable
accomplishment and we're so proud to be
part of uh
what what they've done here and they
look good they look good on tv i think
you know
so i think you hopefully you got to see
some some of the faces
and some of the families uh maybe a few
signs a couple pets
along the way but congratulations
to the to the whole team and thank you
all for everything you've done
i'm going to turn it over to al chen he
is the lead of our swashbuckling edl
team and he's going to tell you a little
bit more about entry descent landing
thanks man uh you know wow that was uh
quite a ride
it never gets old uh landing on mars and
uh
you don't want to tell the whole project
team thank you and especially to the uh
to the edl
family out there i'm really proud of you
uh you guys did it
um i can show you a little bit about uh
what we know so far uh usually it takes
us a couple days to figure out where we
went but with our
side benefit of our train with the
navigation system uh we know
pretty well where we went uh if you
bring up the first figure
you can see that uh we're off the center
just a little bit to the southeast uh
about a kilometer
1.7 kilometers or so to the southeast um
it's a pretty good area uh but train
relative navigation was pretty important
here
if you go to the next figure and not
just for telling us where we are
you can see that we landed in you know
an area that's relatively rugged there
and i think uh ken will be able to tell
you about the science of what's there
but i just worried about what would uh
what would kill us on landing so if you
go to the next slide here
red is generally bad um and you can see
that the uh the system managed to find a
nice blue spot in the midst of all that
red
um all that uh all that death that's out
there for us
so we found the parking lot and uh and
hit it
so um you know this rain water
navigation system was absolutely
essential
in getting us down here and helping us
figure out was where we are right away
we are in a nice flat spot the vehicle
is only tilted by about 1.2 degrees
so we did successfully find that parking
lot
and have a safe rover on the ground and
i couldn't be more proud of my team for
doing that
and that's really all i say
i think this is the end of my journey i
guess with uh with perseverance but the
uh the adventure really the mission is
really just beginning
uh so let me toss it over to jennifer to
talk about the surface work that we have
ahead of us
thanks al well thank you al i mean you
and your team did a
fantastic job and we're so grateful to
be in this position i almost feel like
i'm in a dream
our job is to think of all the bad
things that can happen and try to avoid
those and when all good things happen
you feel like you're dreaming and i'm
happy to feel like i'm dreaming today
and uh happy to be here that i want to
first i want to do the most important
thing
which is introduce you to another
portion of the team
some of these folks were downstairs for
landing and some of them are up here
just doing surface operations and so the
team wants to share their excitement
with you about being on the surface of
mars
getting ready for an amazing science
mission so thank you team
this team is awaiting the odyssey
overflight
yeah let's give them a hand thank you
folks
[Applause]
so this team is awaiting the odyssey
overflight which will happen about
4 4 30 p.m it's a very small data volume
so we won't get very much
information but then at 6 30 p.m trace
gas orbiter will have an overflight and
send down a fair amount of data and
that's
i think what everybody's looking forward
to are these images that mike
talked about so the images we might get
in the if everything goes well
we will likely get the haz cams with the
deployed covers what you were looking at
before
was the haz cams without the covers
deployed we hope
that we will get some thumbnail movies
of some of the edl camera images
so that front row seat and injury
descent and landing
and then it's possible that we'll get an
actual image from the descent
download camera the last 10 meters
before we landed on the surface so
we're all on the edge of our seats
looking forward to getting those images
just a few other stats about the rover
we think we're facing southeast
based on the shadows about 140 degrees
the tilt as al said is
it's flat it's about 1.2 degrees the
the power system looks good the rtg
and the generator before we landed was
at 105 watts and we think it'll go a
little higher
the batteries are charged at 95 percent
and everything
looks great so we are excited to get the
next set of information
from perseverance now the team will get
some images tonight
but then over the next few days we spend
a little bit of time
i'll show you with the model here kind
of unwrapping the rover it's been inside
the descent stage
back shell so the mast is not deployed
so we will deploy
the remote sensing mast here and then
we'll also be pointing
you can see here the high gain antenna
at earth and that's how we will
communicate
right now the rover's sending data
through the orbiters on
an antenna uhf antenna that's sitting
here on the back of the rover
and we can command it but only through
an omnidirectional low gain antenna here
so we don't get very high data rates
through that
so we're excited to be opening up the
rover over the next few days
after that we will transition the
software as john mentioned we were
finishing
many of these people have been working
on this mission for years
and we were finishing the surface flight
software as we were flying to mars
it's on the vehicle but we will spend a
little bit of time transitioning to that
software
then we will finish the checkouts of all
the instruments and we'll drive to our
heli flight demo location wherever that
might be
now we're in i spent a little time
talking to the rover planners the folks
who
decide where to traverse and what's safe
and what's not and there's a ripple
field in front of us between us and the
delta
so we might be doing some driving around
the the ripple field we don't like sand
ripples that much but
we're going to spend some time and
figure out what the traverse
places are and where the helicopter demo
flight should be so that's what we're
working on uh in
in summary i would like to say you know
as i step back it's just
it's great to be able to share this
success i'm so
happy for the team who has worked so
hard this is an incredible team and they
have just
pushed through so many challenges but
we're also very excited to be able to
share this success with
everybody who is cheering for us
everybody who is watching
we really are excited for you to join us
on this great mission on mars that we're
gonna
go through in the next several years
learning more
about mars and with that i'm going to
hand it over to ken farley he'll talk
more about the science mission on mars
hi thanks jennifer uh i would follow on
what uh steve jerzik said i would say
wow we have a science mission it has
been a long road to get here
and one of the things i would point out
uh it may be not obvious from the
outside but
um a mission like this is is a lot like
a decade-long relay race
there's a whole first stage where the
the whole spacecraft was designed and
built
and literally as the pandemic was
closing in was raced off to the cape to
make the launch
the second leg was to get through space
and arrive successfully as
we have just done and the third leg is
the one
that we are about to embark on that's
the science mission
and one of the amazing things about this
is there are thousands of people
all along the way and at each step
those people peel off and move on to new
jobs and so
on behalf of the science team i want to
thank my friends to the right here
and all of the folks that got us to
where we are this is a spectacular place
to be so thank you thank you all so much
for that
and we are going to do you proud in the
science mission
i want to start off uh just saying a few
words about
where we are and what we know so far
this is obviously not based on very much
information
and my phone is buzzing all the time
with people telling me things so we're
already starting to process the
information that we have but
in this first image you can see that we
landed to the
southeast of the delta we are about two
kilometers to the southeast
of the delta and we are actually
right on the boundary between two
different geologic units there's the
kind of smooth area that we landed on we
call that the mafic floor unit
and then there's the rough area this is
actually where the dunes are
and that's the olivine bearing unit and
this is a great place to be
because one of the things that
scientists love to do is
look to see how two different geologic
units come together it tells you a lot
about the geologic history
so we're really excited to get going on
this um and if i could have the next
image
so these images i i hope everybody
understands
these are actually taken in only one of
the color bands
this is just in the red color band and
they are actually taken through the
protective lens cap that is
on the camera so these are these are
just amazing things that we got back in
the first few seconds after we landed
but we can already see some important
things uh there are
rocks in this field of view they're uh
we don't know exactly how big they are
but they might be
uh about 10 centimeters would be a
reasonable guess
um so those are those are going to be
very interesting they will
undoubtedly be some of the first objects
that we explore
once uh the kind of shakedown phase of
the
early rover operations completes and
also in the background we believe that
we can see the delta
there there are features in the back
that look like the cliffs of the delta
so when we get those additional images
back that jennifer was mentioning we
should know a lot more about that
and then we can also see um some sand
dunes in there
and and actually uh in something of a
relief our imaging scientist told me
when i went and talked to him about this
image
i asked him what he saw and he said
looks like mars so i'm glad we have
successfully landed on mars
so science team is uh really excited to
get going here we have uh
years of scientific investigation ahead
of us and i will turn it back to xiaoru
for questions
okay thank you ken um we're about to
start q a
so if you're a reporter on our phone
lines uh remember that you can press
star one and get into the queue
and if you're on social media and you
want to ask questions use the hashtag
countdown to mars so our first reporter
question
comes from steve futterman of cbs news
go ahead steve
and uh congratulations to everyone
involved in this i'd like to focus my
question
to matt wallace and al chen obviously
we see you through the lenses of the
cameras as this is happening
could you take a step back and maybe
describe
for us what was going through your mind
your hearts
what were the emotions as the the seven
minutes of terror were taking place and
the reaction when you knew that
that perseverance had safely touched
down on mars
but you know it's hard to really
describe
to be honest with you you think you're
prepared
for it it's part of our business
in some ways you know we're exploring
we're going places we haven't been
we know there's risk we know there's
uncertainty
i was telling somebody the other day i
don't think a single work day went by
for the last eight or nine years where i
didn't
think about entry descendant landing you
know you always worry
did you make the right decision did you
test the right things
did you put the right people in charge
we clearly did
on perseverance but it just
um it consumes you it becomes part of
you
and um in in some ways
uh it's hard still to believe uh that we
finished it and that we're done
you know it still feels a little surreal
uh because it just becomes embedded in
in the way you
you think um you have to be constantly
terrified
uh of it you have to respect it at the
same time you have to
somehow believe that you can do it or
else you'd never try to put a car
on the surface of mars right it's crazy
um
and so uh it's part of our it's part of
what we do
i guess and at some point um it becomes
part of how you think
but but there really is no good way to
describe
that moment when it's over and you hear
those words uh touchdown confirmed
it's just a remarkable feeling of um
of pride in the team uh relief
uh and um and really joy
thinking forward to this remarkable
service mission that we have coming up
that's the best i can do
let me let me turn it over to al i mean
those submits are still pretty raw for
me right now but the
uh yeah it's you know the vehicle is
going on a roller coaster ride
and you are too right the the little
pieces of uh
of data come back things seem to be
working the way you want to go
you know you start getting you start
feeling good and then you know something
comes by that doesn't quite match what
you thought it was going to be
is that really right you should have
expected that or something comes out of
water
and your stomach drops and then you know
okay the things are okay again right
then you pick up that uh
next piece of information that says
things are actually going okay
um it's an emotional rollercoaster ride
all the way down
uh that way and you're you know you're
second guessing yourself as you go
even though it's already happened it's
kind of crazy
um and uh yeah i mean it's
it's a feeling of being very fortunate
at the end i think for me
that uh i get to work at a place with uh
with with people
who are both great engineers and great
people and we still get to
dare mighty things together so thank you
great thank you okay our next caller is
marcia dunn of the ap
go ahead marcia yes hi uh
congratulations
for l um all those blue dots surround
sorry all the red dots surrounding the
little blue patch
are those mostly rocks how close do you
think you came from
something that could have doomed the
mission on landing thank you
we'll have to take a closer look at
exactly uh what we had there
i will tell you that in general we make
these maps a little scarier because we
want to make sure that we find the
safest spots in fact these maps are
typically saturated at
what we consider uh four percent hazard
so that if you came down there
i mean some of these places are
definitely problems but and there's
individual rocks that are marked there
um so we're gonna have to take a closer
look to see how close we came uh but we
definitely you know
the system did what it was supposed to
do it found the uh
the safest area that was available to it
and and went there
great okay thank you next call is from
paul brinkman of upi
hello yes thanks for taking my question
um
i'm wondering if someone can uh i
realize you haven't seen the
descent images yet but um to what extent
do you expect
any major changes in uh perseverance's
perseverance is planned route based on
those images
and about how much imagery do you think
you're going to get i mean in terms of
the number of images or video
and how much better will those be than
than what you have from the orbiters
uh i don't know if that would be for uh
lori or uh
for jennifer go ahead lori or no your
point of jennifer i think jennifer would
okay go ahead jennifer
well why don't i i can talk a little bit
about the images um
we think over the next few days we'll
get all of the entry descent
and landing um movies down so that we
can see
basically that front row seat of what
happened all the different cameras and
we'll get those movies
i think as far as the where we might go
once we see those
i can probably toss that over to ken and
see what he says about that
yeah i expect that what we will do is we
will explore that contact that i
mentioned between the mafic floor unit
and the uh
and the olivine unit and as jennifer
mentioned
that's a dune field and we might have to
go around the dune field but i suspect
we will go around it
either one direction or the other uh
towards the delta
great okay thank you we'll take our next
reporter question
from sam ahmed of afp
go ahead sam hi thanks for taking my
question congratulations
um we understand we we had uh two mikes
on board when when might we know if we
uh if a perseverance was successful in
recording
um the first direct sound from mars
jennifer you want to take that one yeah
we should be able to get some of that
information in the overnight passes
tonight and tomorrow morning so
hopefully we'll
we'll be able to understand whether we
got the sounds and what those sounded
like
thanks great okay thank you next
reporter is kate tobin from pbs newshour
yes can you hear me yes we can
wonderful congratulations to the team
great great job and
and my question follows on the last two
about the uh
about the imagery from uh from the
cameras that you
put on to the descent vehicle and on the
rover itself uh
can you talk a little bit you say
they're gonna come down
uh starting tonight and overnight
is that all of them i know there were
some gopro
type sort of rugged sports cameras that
you had pointed in all different
directions and some high-speed uh video
that you were taking
do you expect it all to come down in the
next
uh you know a few hours or is that
something that's going to trickle in
over days and when do you expect to
release it
so let's let matt take this one go ahead
matt yeah i can give you a
kind of an overview there um and and
you're correct yes as i think thomas
mentioned or
others had mentioned for the first time
we're going to be able to see ourselves
in high definition video
land on another planet we we put
commercial ruggedized cameras at various
locations on the vehicle
three of them looking up at that big
supersonic parachute
one on the descent stage looking down at
the rover one on the rover
that looks up at the descent stage and
then we have one at the rover looking
down
as well and so we think we're going to
capture some pretty spectacular
uh we think we have captured hopefully
some pretty spectacular
video and they come with a microphone as
well
and so i think that's what you're asking
about um
we are in fact hoping that we can bring
one image one still image from those
cameras
uh to the table tomorrow
from the descent stage looking down at
the rover
and and i think that's gonna hopefully
uh we'll see that
and and then i'm hoping that that's
gonna be a remarkable image
but the first video product uh we're
gonna work on
over the weekend as the imagery comes
down and we're going to try to bring
that
uh to to a press conference on monday
and i think that's really going to be
something to see
yeah it's it's going to be remarkable
i'm looking forward to it myself
thank you thank you okay our next
reporter is stephen clark
from space flight now go ahead stephen
hi thank you for taking my question um
just wondering if maybe jennifer
crossbar can go through
the time line over the next couple of
days and some more detail about
you know when the lens covers are going
to be open when the
high gain antenna will have a lock on
earth
and when the mast will be uh
you know deployed and when the first
drive might be
uh just walk me through that for me
please and maybe for uh
dr zubrukin or dr glaze um you know the
mars sample
campaign sample return campaign was
really hindering on the outcome of today
just wanted to get your comments on on
any relief that you felt that
you know that your you know your whole
mars sample return strategy
um is reality now after today's outcome
thanks
yeah i'll start with uh what what we're
doing over the next several saws
this is sal zero so right after the
rover landed it actually fired some
pyros and did release our high gain
antenna
and also release those lens covers which
is why the images that we expect to see
this evening
will be without the lens covers and
those will be the has cam
images along with the other images we
talked about
the first four or five solves what we're
trying to do is get the power the
thermal and the communications the
infrastructure of the rover
stabilized so that then we can go and
load the software as i mentioned
so the the first thing we'll do tomorrow
we actually gyro compass today as well
to see if we can understand our
orientation such that tomorrow on saw
one
we can point the high gain antenna at
earth and then
if we get good pointing then we'll start
commanding
the vehicle through that antenna and
that's one of the key things we're
trying to do in these early days is get
that
communication link working we'll also
release the remote sensing mast
and then on salt 2 we'll deploy that
mass now while we're doing these things
which i call our critical path
infrastructure things
we're also doing other health checks of
other
instruments and over the course of the
three cells or four saws of the
these early activities get all the
instrument health checks done we'll
charge the rover battery
on that saw too once we deploy the mast
that's when we'll take those initial
images with our double e cams these
their camera that they're their color
this time in the past they've been black
and white
we'll take those first panoramas and
then the mass cam z
which is also on the mast we'll take
those panoramas on saw three
and then those will be sending that data
down along with additional data from the
edl cameras and the other data that we
talked about over this week
it'll take us till about solve four and
solve for we actually start to load
um and burn into the the rce
so our flight computers the new software
and once we start to do that we do about
four days of transitioning to the new
software we do it very carefully we toe
dip we make sure
that nothing goes wrong and at the end
of that is when we start the next set of
checkouts where we'll
deploy the arm we'll do our first drive
about
five meters forward and back and then
once we get that checked out is when
we'll start to drive
towards a heli site we'll have figured
out where we want to fly the heli
uh we need there are certain
requirements of of that site in terms of
rock sizes and flatness and so we're
looking for that right now
that ends up being you know a few weeks
before we get there but
uh but we're excited about it all
wonderful i want to quickly talk about
your second question that's even and
that is uh
of course uh there's a lot of friends
all over the world
who had a sigh of relief and everything
went well
with this touchdown uh the mars sample
return
uh colleagues they're all working really
hard to retire the risks of these new
technologies and to bring together
two of the most amazing missions to now
bring
the samples back a work that i started
years ago technology development and and
the system development here at
jpl at the european space agency and
elsewhere
there's two principles we used to set
the timing the first one is
we always bet on success in our business
even if
you sweat through shirt or not like i
learned about john you know we bet on
success
because that's what we want to achieve
that's what we're planning for
the second one is to go right now
and develop the more sample return
campaign not only
makes the service mission more effective
in that regard but also
it actually saves a lot of money because
we actually can use the systems that we
have now
move towards that return and so for that
reason i think uh
there's a lot of people being excited
right now all over the world
but uh yeah lori anything you wanted to
add that i may have overlooked in this
i i think you've covered that really
well the the only thing i would say is
that
you know it's always nerve-wracking to
as we go through the the edl for a
lander or a rover
um but it was doubly so this time
because as you say the the march sample
return
uh was also pretty you know re is is
reliant on the success of
of perseverance so yeah we all
definitely heave decide relief
uh in thinking forward on on all the
work that that's to go
uh from our sample return but really
really exciting that we've now
really embarked on that chapter one of
mars sample return
um in for real so it's great
okay thank you lori okay we're gonna do
a social media question
this might also actually be for lori
pulls to do on instagram
asks if perseverance finds signs of past
or present life
what would we do next oh wow that's a
great
great question um because there's still
just so much to do
on mars it's a fascinating fascinating
place and there's
there's a it's a wonderful laboratory
for doing incredible science
and uh you know certainly the big
question for us right now is this
question about
uh the evolution of mars and the and the
existence or not of
of past life that's been preserved at
jezreel crater and that's our focus
right now
um you know but we're always looking
forward to the additional science that
we're going to do in the future i'm
thinking about
uh again how planets form how they
evolve and mars is a great great place
to
to work on all of those different
science questions
great thank you okay we're going to go
back to the reporter phone lines
and we have mike wall of space.com
thank you all and um yeah
congratulations it was it was a really
great day for all of us watching too
um just just to kind of piggyback off of
um stephen clark's question about
what the near future holds could you
maybe jennifer or john or
or ken like um do you go out like
like another couple weeks or a month or
so i mean how long do you anticipate
it'll take to get to the helicopter site
and how long will those flights take and
i mean when will the rover be able to
actually like start doing science and
like start gathering samples and so on
and so forth do you think
thank you sure i'll go a little further
out i talked about we'll have the
road once we get the robotic arm working
and we get mobility working we'll go
find the heli flight demo site so it's
about three weeks
and then depending on how close that
site is uh
we have to traverse to it and we still
have the helicopter underneath the rover
so we can't use our auto
auto navigation we have to be a little
bit more careful when we're doing that
so it could take up to tencel it really
depends on where we find a heli flight
demo
site then we will spend 30 solves
assault is a martian day
it's 40 minutes longer than an earth day
so we speak in solves when we're doing
operations on mars so we spend about 30
sols
um for the helicopter demo prior to that
it'll take us
about a ten sols to get the helicopter
just deployed
underneath the rover move the rover away
we go about 100 meters away before we
fly it
so that's another 40 saw so i i like to
say it's it's sometimes hard to
it's always hard to estimate exactly
when things happen but
we'll be flying the helicopter in the
spring here and we'll be spending spring
fly in the helicopter after that
we're going to upgrade our auto
navigation capability on the rover
meaning we're just going to try it out
make sure it works then we'll
drive towards the first science site
that ken and his team are interested in
going to
again that depends on where they want to
go how long it takes us to get there and
that's the point where we
where we will be doing the first
sampling so i like to say summer
is the time frame when we'll be doing
the first sampling those things can
change they might go faster
or if we have to drive traverse to
different places that take a longer
period of time it might go slower
that's a longer plan and then one thing
i'll just throw in the end conjunction
is around september where we um do not
we're not able to
communicate with the spacecraft because
the sun is between earth and mars
and so during that time we'll spend a
little bit of work uh
finishing off some efficiency and
operability capabilities for the vehicle
to help it
be even smarter and even more autonomous
and then after conjunction we'll upload
that new flight software build
and then that's when we can really do
things even faster than we had
originally planned
ken do you want to talk a little bit
about the science part
yeah it's a little premature to say very
much yet um
i i i mentioned uh in a previous
discussion that
there are 450 science team members and i
i think most of them are sending me
texts and emails about what we should do
now
but we've got to get together and
actually come up with a communal plan
we're not ready to do that just yet
okay great thank you okay the next
reporter question comes from jackie
goddard of the times of london
hello and congratulations everyone and
that includes
uh all the folks on those screens at
your kitchen tables and your
uh on your couches with your dogs and
your cats and your kids
um my question is can one of you on the
panel please give us some examples of
the complexity
of the challenges that you've faced
getting this mission to mars under
pandemic conditions
and to what extent will covid continue
to affect operations for example with
the rover operations
also their kitchen tables and sofas and
pets on laps um
or does that now change thank you
yeah i can i can start us off and say a
few words um
i'll let jennifer say a bit about
looking out into the future the surface
mission uh you know
the pandemic struck at just about the
worst time
for this mission and we had just shipped
the vehicle down to
kennedy space center it was in pieces we
still had to
put it together it's a critical point in
time for us
you can't make mistakes there's no
safety net at that point there's no
double checks you have to do it right
we were still finishing some of the
flight hardware back here
at jpl um we had very little schedule
margin
you know the teams were already working
multiple shifts and
had already scheduled out the weekends
and uh
you know we had to react very quickly
and and we were
normally you're just focused on trying
to do the job do it right
and uh get it done in time to make the
planetary launch window because if you
miss it
you're gonna have to wait two years um
and uh and suddenly the we had to start
thinking
primarily about how to keep the team
safe and their family safe
and um and how to get through all these
logistical challenges
uh you know we were quickly trying to
understand the protective equipment we
had to bring in
um what kind of social distancing we had
to deal with how many people could stand
around the rover
and how close could they be inside a
clean room you know
what kind of protection we got from our
cleanroom garb
we we were just struggling to understand
if
all of our support community the
companies that just
clean the garments you know for our
clean room or bring the nitrogen in for
our thermal vacuum chambers whether or
not they were going to be there and
continue
to deliver the things that we needed to
keep
to keep going we had people
here at jpl that had to travel to
kennedy space center and we couldn't get
them we couldn't travel commercially
and so we had to ask for some help from
nasa headquarters our friends at
armstrong
uh gave us a jet if i helped us with the
transporting via an agency jet back and
forth
our we got support out of wallops um
another nasa facility to fly some of our
flight hardware there
and and back so it was a very very
challenging
uh time and and then we had to figure
out how to
actually launch the thing and and fly it
when
you know we had all these constraints as
well
we were modifying our processes and
protocols in our operations facility
um you know very just very very
challenging
um you know in the team uh i think that
the team like all of you uh uh out there
they're worried you know worried about
their parents or grandparents
and and uh just worried about
their kids out of school worried about
taking care of you know
uh kids at home and do doing their work
um
so it was it was a tough time we
actually um
we decided to try to mark it we we put a
um
a plate a covered plate on the port side
of the rover
it's now sitting on jezero crater uh
you know with the with the vehicle uh in
an
and you can see the video there of us
installing that plate
uh down at kennedy space center uh
and that plate is really there to
symbolize the challenge that
not just our team was facing but
everybody has been facing
it's been a tough year it's been tough
to do this mission
uh under these uh uh in this environment
uh but the team uh like they have with
every other challenge has stepped up to
it we got a lot of help
from the institution from the agency
and i think and i think that's going to
continue
into the future so that we can do this
surface mission
uh jennifer do you want to add anything
well i'll add that
we are not all together and that's very
unusual for
a landing and when we start a surface
operations ken's talking about his phone
blowing up
usually that would be a big meeting
that's in one of the buildings here in
the laboratory where we all talk about
what the
science of the mission is and based on
where we are what we want to do
the engineering team is largely on site
right now
and to finish development was a struggle
being remote
because these are complex systems they
take a lot of individual expertise
put put together in a way that we can
operate a vehicle that we can build
software that makes that vehicle work
and doing all of that remotely without
as much
interaction has been hard for the team
we have
the science team now is fully remote and
so
and you know it's just like all of you
guys i mean i work from my laundry room
for the last several months
right and my kids are in zoom school and
they'll walk in and then people say
they can't hear me because the washer is
going i mean everybody has these
challenges that are going on because
this is not
the way we typically would design a mars
mission
but the team has been fantastic and just
overcome every challenge we actually
have
we have now uh robots on the floor where
if you're remote but you want to
go look in a room you can log into one
of the robots and you can drive it
around the floor now and surface
operations and
and go talk to the people that you want
so we we've we've learned a lot
about how to do things remotely i think
it has changed how we think about the
problem but it is
it is challenging and i look forward to
the time i think there will be a time
when we can all be together again and
not have all the restrictions
i'm in a room by myself which is the
only reason i'm not wearing a mask
and i think that that does make it um
one of the things i thought
the team missed out on a little bit was
just that excitement and energy that
comes from being
all together right before landing and so
we were together but it was remotely
and so i think it'll be fun and great
for the team to be able to get back
together again when we can do that
okay thanks jennifer next call comes
from amanda khan
of the la times hi
uh thank you so much for taking my call
can you hear me
yes okay great um so
um i had a couple of questions here um
congratulations um
to jump off of that that last question i
was sort of wondering if
all these pandemic restrictions will be
affecting um
how uh you guys deal with with mars time
will that be affecting the mars time
experience
and and also will it be affecting the
experience of
um the rover drivers um how will that be
changing because of the pandemic
yeah well the mars time question is
great we
so mars time as you obviously know
you've asked the question
is uh we get up in the morning on mars
and then our clock shifts by 40 minutes
every day
so when you're all here and you're
together
uh that kind of works but when you're
sitting in your living room
or you know in a small room in your
house if you need to be on a telecon
all night long planning the rover's
sequences for the next day that may not
work out for your spouse or your family
or
those things so we've had to change in
some cases we've actually had to create
remote but on-site places for people to
come to we don't want to gather too many
people together
we need to have our socially distant
facilities but we
have several i would say we have a
couple dozen people who
are remote but still coming to lab to
different areas
during mars time so that they can uh not
interfere with their family's life which
is not on mars time
and then as far as our rover planners
they're going to get busy is
that they already have some meshes where
they're trying to come up with strategic
traverses
uh with the images we we have but i
think it's the same for them we
they have some unique equipment they
need to use so again we've set up some
different locations
where they can come in and use that
equipment it doesn't have to all be
we have some over in this building and
then we've set some up in another
building so rover planners who can't be
at home on mars time can come in
so it is it is different and it's
different for the families and
we'll see how it we'll see how it works
um we do have
probably about 50 people in here that
when they work mars time they're
actually
at the facility and on console as you
see behind me
great okay thanks jennifer okay the next
call comes from leo enright
of irish tv uh
thanks very much uh yuri um
and as we say in the irish language
kogordus ukri uh to everybody involved
particularly the people
on the zoom screen uh many
congratulations
uh i had a very detailed geology
question ready
for ken farley but uh jennifer
trosper mentioned a robot that they're
using
to communicate i i wasn't quite clear
about that
so i thought i would ask about that a
bit more
you said you're a robot that can move
and talk to people let me yeah i'll
clarify it's a robot that you can log
into and essentially
drive it around and your face will be
there and you can
zoom up you can drive up next to
somebody that you want to talk to
closer than six feet and then you can
have a conversation
with them from your home it's it's a
zoom meeting but
you have a movable zoom meeting it's a
way to think about it
uh can you describe the technology i
mean is it a rover
or what is it no it's just a robot that
moves around
the i can't remember the actual um maker
maybe somebody can help me out with that
but it's a
it's a robot that we drive remotely
around the floor it's
it really just has wheels and then a
screen it's a
moving computer screen maybe that's a
better way to describe it
could i do a follow-up sure we can do
that we'll yeah
sure okay thanks because i did have a
question for ken farley
um ken i i you know this zoom screen
is fantastic because we're all used to
the crowd
coming in in jpl after a landing
and the other tradition in jbl after a
landing
is the journalist with the geeky
question
uh so i just wanted to ask you could you
clarify
uh have you landed at kanyon
and if that is where you have landed
um can you tell me whether you've looked
at
channel islands and the outcrop there
that does appear to be a delta formation
and would you consider doing a quick
run to channel islands rather than
a long run over to the delta
yeah okay so let's let's uh clarify
what's going on here so the science team
has associated specific um
uh earth locations they happen to be
national parks and preserves
to specific regions in jezreel crater
and it is from those quadrangles we call
them those quadrangles on earth that we
will draw
the names that we informally attach to
features
that we look at and we take observations
of
so we have in fact landed in the canyon
de shea quad
um and uh the uh
i'm not sure exactly where the the
feature that you are referring to
is i still think that our most likely
ultimate destination
uh is going to be to the west northwest
and that we will very likely go up to
the delta front that in on the image you
see right now is in the
in the upper left-hand corner
okay we're going to end on a social
media question
so vince on youtube asks was the landing
today
the best one so far uh
i'll ask matt that question first yeah
yes 100
it was the um you know i
this is my fifth mars rover at jennifer
and a handful of other
uh others of us on the project to work
uh
you know uh a number of these and uh
it's uh they're all very very special i
have to say
but uh as of this moment right now this
is the best landing
on mars i would have to say all right
great thank you that's all the time that
we have for questions today
if you're a member of the media and you
still have a question you can contact
the jpl digital news and media office
we'll continue to answer some questions
on social media
and tune in to nasa tv and online
tomorrow we'll have another news
briefing at 10 a.m pacific time and
we'll give you an update about the start
of the surface mission
you know if you want some more updates
you can also go online
to nasa.gov perseverance
and mars.nasa.gov perseverance for
additional information
you can also follow us on social media
at nasa persevere
now one last thing before we go i just
wanted to say that if you wanted to
welcome our latest robotic explorer to
mars mars will be visible in the night
sky tonight it'll be right next to the
moon so have a look
thank you very much for joining us and
go perseverance
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you